well Jonathan Felicia congratulations
both of you've made it through the first
round of this competition which means
you're going into the final round back
at your home forges where you'll be
building an iconic blade from history
now placement Stewie favor and take a
look over your right shoulder
that ship right there is a Charles W
Morgan it is the last wooden whaling
ship in existence now on that ship
Willow should be out at Sea using a
variety of tools but this final round of
competition we want you to build a
specific one of them fightspace you will
be building this
this is the fencing knife
[Music]
dating back to the 18th century the
flensing knife also called The mincing
Knife was a vital tool for the American
whaling industry this blade featured a
long curved very sharp edge design to
remove blubber from large whales the
flensing knife was used routinely on
board massive whaling ships which acted
as floating factories harvesting blubber
and boiling it down in their onboard
furnaces to create high quality oil that
helped turn America into an industrial
Powerhouse one of the last remaining
wooden whaling ships in existence is
docked right here at the Mystic Seaport
Museum good luck bites Miss we will see
you right back here at Mystic Seaport
Museum in four days
my name is Felicia Howard I am 18 years
old I'm from Catoosa Oklahoma and I am a
full-time bladesmith I'm not sure what
we're doing I don't know how we're going
to do it and I'm a little bit worried
if I won ten thousand dollars I would
repay my mom and dad for that brand new
Anvil I took out a business loan from
them and it would be great to be able to
pay that back
I've decided that I want the socket on
the outside of my shaft and so I just
wanted to draw that out to width and get
it wrapped I have finished the forging
part of my flinting knife I am ready for
quench
[Music]
oh it's pretty significant it is pretty
warped and so I think I'm gonna have to
re-quench it I just love redoing work
you know it's so much fun
since I already quenched it there is
risk of over stressing your steel which
can cause fracturing but that or could
prevent it from performing well
it's straight it worked out pretty great
there have been a lot of challenges but
I'm pretty happy with the build
yeah it's pretty it's pretty sure
it's Jonathan Howe I'm 33 years old I'm
from Groton New York I have been
bladesmithing for about four years I got
into it because I am also a martial
artist and I make my own practice
weapons I have no idea what to expect
because it's forged from a single piece
of Steel there is no seam no connection
point between the socket and the knife
and that Junction is a crucial part a
hit on gold medal could cause stress
fractures that can show up later I'm
going to start working on the blade
getting it in line with the socket
starting to put the curve into it
I've got the blade hardened quenched
tempered all yesterday so today is all
about starting the handle so I've got
the six foot piece of Hickory
I need to remove a bunch of material so
that I can actually slide into the
integral socket on the blade and then I
can start removing material on the
handle to make it comfortable I need to
make sure everything's tight because if
it's too loose when they go to test it
it could just fall apart ready for the
handle
nice tight mechanical fit I'm pretty
confident with the construction of my
weapon there is a bit of epoxy in there
to keep the wood from moving around and
I have two brass pins for the mechanical
combination Advantage being a martial
artist I have to test it I want to know
how it feels overall I just want to play
with it
oh that is sharp
basements welcome to the dynamic kill
test
Jonathan you're up first you ready for
this yes sir I'm nervous
[Music]
foreign
song about your fencing knife here first
up the handle here it's nice and oh void
and it really fits my hand for a grip
and good retention your Edge held up
nicely no issues nice balance
wieldability and lethality is good and
overall
keel
all right Felicia your turn you ready
sure let's do this
since I had to re-quench my blade a
couple times the edge might break off or
roll I could win or it could break
gloriously and I could lose
[Music]
foreign
light weapon that you have designed over
here I like the way it feels with the
handle here your Edge Cuts very deep
into this ballistics dummy but during
the test you have two points right here
where it took a little bit of a chip but
I like the way it feels and overall your
flancing knife
you'll kill
thanks
[Music]
all right bladesmiths Welcome to our
Dynamic strength test the fish and duck
pole chop
Jonathan you're up first you ready for
this yes sir okay
[Music]
foreign
dude
all right Jonathan the blade was cutting
beautifully it was holding up nicely but
I started to feel loosen a little bit
what really caused that break was the
pin the pin is very close to the edge of
your shaft here all that dress goes
right into the pin and or right around
the shoulder and you can see
this is where it broke
[Music]
this was going so well we thought you're
going to make it all
work so your blade did take a
catastrophic failure on the seventh
strike on the dock pull here you're not
out of the fight yet you know how this
goes Felicia in order to take home the
title of Fortune fire champion and get a
check for ten thousand dollars your
blade will have to survive all of these
fish and seven strikes on the poles are
you ready
sure all right Dave take it away
here we go again
having already taken Edge damage I don't
know if my blank can handle certain
strikes
I can totally see my blade just
shattering around the post flying off
into the water
I am not optimistic and my blade Will
Survive
everything held up
Felicia congratulations your blade made
it through all the strikes in our tests
now Jonathan you're clearly a talented
Smith you fought so hard through this
Mystic Seaport challenge but
unfortunately because your blade did
suffer a catastrophic failure during her
test your time in this competition has
ended we want to say thank you for
coming out and trying so hard
thank you sir thank you Jonathan thank
you I'm very disappointed my handle
broke
but I had a wonderful time well Felicia
that means you are the new Fortune fire
Champion you are the youngest female
champion you'll be receiving a check for
ten thousand dollars well done
if I can get some exposure being a woman
in a very unsaturated Market
I'm so excited this is so cool
like I won
now I can actually repay my mom and dad
for that brand new anvil